grape vines Ryan Jacobson's German
ancestors planted them here more than a
hundred years ago when they settled as
farmers in central California since then
the family has survived several droughts
the drought here in the San Joaquin
Valley is absolutely the worst we've
ever seen and what we're looking at as
far as this year we're looking at
hundreds of thousands of acres being
fallowed tens of thousands of jobs being
lost and billions of dollars of economic
activity not coming to this community
high temperatures in winter f dry as
dust fields that with it because the
usual winter rains failed to materialize
here where most of the fruit and
vegetables in the US are grown the
harvest is likely to be meager this year
food prices will rise but that won't
compensate for the farmers losses Ryan
Jacobson and thousands of other farmers
fear for their livelihood he's here
which is we're in year three of a
drought that we don't know how long it's
going to last farmer there are farmers
that probably will go under this year
that will no longer be in business and
based off of how long this lasts there
are farmers that cannot go through this
for very many years in a row before
they're going to have to go under the
large neighboring farm which belongs to
the stimulus produce company isn't ready
to go under yet it employs 300 staffers
and several thousand seasonal workers
but the extreme drought has left its
mark here two hours drive from San
Francisco
as you can see over here there's a big
piece of land about 650 acres it's
fallow it's empty because there's simply
not enough water to our farm the farms
43 year old manager is under no
illusions the drought will cost the
company a lot of money what does that
mean with a quarter of the land can't be
farmed it means that the company is
probably going to have to suffer loss of
money loss of revenue loss of profit and
we're just barely surviving as it is
we're hoping that the water that we can
pump from the wells will be enough to
form something in this area but well
water alone isn't enough to irrigate the
fields especially as the low water table
is sinking even further this water comes
from reservoirs it's transported many
miles to the fields via canals it's a
time consuming and expensive process
irrigating this comparatively small
field for a few hours costs a hundred
dollars the process has to be repeated
several times a week for the crops to
grow but now the reservoirs are emptying
the Sun that we reservoir is one of the
most important in the region and it's
only forty percent full scientists in
California expect the situation to
worsen in the future there's very high
consensus around increasing droughts in
the future related to global climate
change because not only are we having
earlier snowmelt and less snow pack
which is one of our largest water
reservoirs in the western US but we're
also having hotter temperatures which
means that outdoor plants require more
water to survive that will force people
to manage their resources differently in
the past we have had droughts but
they've typically been two to three
years which means that we can wait for a
wet year that might not be what happens
in the future if we look at the science
it tells us that we're likely to see
longer and more severe droughts and as
that begins to happen people are really
going to have to think about water
differently
filled with water efficiency is the only
way that Ryan Jacobson will be able to
secure his livelihood in the long term
once the water enters the system it's
delivered directly right to the root
zone doesn't have any kind of waste or
evaporative losses of any kind so as you
can see here as we pull this up a little
bit it's anywhere between six and eight
inches deep here but it goes right below
the plant and right here we happen to
see as we go into dig into here we get
the crop and you could tell that it was
right next to where this where this
plant was one day his son maverick will
take over the farm he's already making
friends with the right animals goats are
known to be very low-maintenance and can
manage fine in dry climates